I'm scared I'll burn for you Dogon but
Noah Kendall you owe me a lot of scrap
paper I expect you to deliver on your
promise every new day holds a promise
ended advancing yourself furthering your
prospects and your career as a future
employee of a corporation of your choice
your possibilities are infinite lies and
unlocking your inner potential through
hard work and relentless dedication as
an employee you are expected to perform
at the top of your abilities last day
huh keep you here forever leach work is
rewarding maybe you'd like another three
months
laziness time it would be so easy
personal freedom comes at optimized
let's go you've got a full day ahead our
great society expects every employee you
contribute for the corporation of their
choice for several
or nation human names ready for
conditional release though if it was up
to me upon relief you must seek
immediate employment and will be
monitored through your grid link if you
do not find employment within 14 days
you'll be relocated to a green land
facility do you understand these
conditions just get me out of here
dressing rooms to the left bleach and
enjoy ridges
Dogen sends his best
enjoy your freedom back to our fair city
of glass all of agent operations operate
here and so there is the anthem
opportunity for you to find new
employment and lead a happy and
productive life you ever been given a
rare as I mentioned
and on behalf of the Cougars that Canada
more fair city glass
come on
I'm a Juris Noah sent me
you could be anyone well you'll just
have to trust me here take this
get off the streets but put it on I need
to get connected in Pella
I don't know is he going to talk to you
with the horizontal
what the hell
there's something wrong with this
sorry almost forgot we have to cut your
grid link it's causing the interference
is this what the employees see all the
time yeah yes you're not reformed enough
to enjoy it I'm not reformed at all
there you go
they're off the grid now they know
you're gone I'll get off the ground
I'll go the other way lead you up ahead
know why she's out I gave her the P link
and she's off the grid
thank you there
I
and their voice but Kasich off your tail
because you said that done no one they
seem hell-bent on fine
you got it covered
Paige you should be coming up on an old
warehouse soon get inside it
submit
so what tell me what the hell is going
on they were gonna sing it to a great
length don't faith now cutting your grid
link makes you a fugitive faulty plan
for this follow the runner egg goes
through the warehouse the chorus will
meet up with you on the other side by
then you should be clear that old place
Oh
that's a channel search warrant out for
Phoenix carpet or female young carpenter
yeah
so consider up with the defeat grid
print well they took her I treasure that
door people Incas insurance become an
antique later
this has changed since you were taken
career sucker comes down hard on even
the tiniest policy infractions
yeah I can't be easy to break you ever
hear this I almost paint
control
right
I asked nicely they wouldn't step aside
and now they know you came this way like
I had a choice sure we need to clear out
I'd better take a different route to the
Everdeen tower we'll split up again keep
them confused can you make it across to
those pipes of course good your bead
links should be calibrated by now and
your runners vision working just follow
the red and I'll meet you at the tower
let's go
dude
sooo close
you know I bet you're on a different
route to the tower cave they broke the
intersection
okay working out a little something what
you get there
the office
just drop several squads in jeopardize
our dammit
eggless
into beer I'm going to buy him a
Christmas is there
a second everywhere supply to the lion
I'm a Mariah
good going fish
I think I lost them did L two years in
prison only made you better at this get
to Araya
Oh at least you got here before dawn who
are you anyway when did you join the
Cabal about a year ago well I grew up
with them so how about you come down and
caused a whole lot of trouble you don't
know what happened I know enough and
safer than you I'm here with new guy in
his ego I can do it
Stryker's faith all right let's get
started
remember to use your surroundings check
that you were really hurt for sure
and better of course is if you got them
into one another one
all right jisuk comms have calmed down a
little but they know you're out there so
I faith and they don't know what to go
to the tower to get out in the streets
are not an option
go to ground if we can avoid it you know
that Icarus
nice kick
that's right face
step on the Connors family mysteries
he'll get by ikarus
impose now waiting for a head don't
underestimate them faith already
yes one more thing is they can [ __ ]
love some special unit being sent and
continue to roll or something
they're always monitor runner
that's a negative control no visual she
couldn't have survived that let the
cleanup crew dig up the body I got
better things to do
yeah she took out all Senate EMT too
while you're at it
if I shouldn't be so surprised to get a
second so upset and it's your specialty
after all in the future seems they can
prove that combat training
oh I move the Cabal while you were away
you'll find this in the separate transit
now now come on kiddo
you